راس شقير في خليج السويس وعلى بعد
350 كيلو مترا من القاهره تعمل ست شركات
بترول في مجال التنقيب فضلا عن معملين في
مجال التكرير شركات تعمل على مدى عقود
اتهمت مؤخرا بتدمير الشعب المرجانيه في
البحر الاحمر اتهام دحده ونفاه وزير
البترول ووزيره البيئه من خلال جوله وشرح
علمي لما يتم اتخاذه من اجراءات للمحافظه
على البيئه وعلى تلك الشعب التي تعد
الاغنى عالميا
البترولي وكمان في كمان خطط استكمال
لهذه المنظومه وفي نفس الوقت لم يتم
التاثير السلبي على الشعب المرجانيه همم
ولازم كمان نقول انه الشباب المرجانيه مش
في مصر في العالم كله حصل لها بعد
التغيرات نتيجه
بس الحراري
وسخونه مياه البحار وبعض العوامل الاخرى
زي المخلفات البلاستيكيه وبعض الانشطه
البحريه الاخرى ليست لها علاقه بالانشطه
البتروليه احنا يمكن الشكل واللون بتاعه
الشعاب المرجانيه اللي شفناها لايف من
ساعتين ودلوقتي موجوده برده جوه للكاميرات
اللي موجوده تحت الميه بتورينا ان حصل
تعافي سريع في الشعاب المرجانيه اللي
موجوده في هذا المكان مصر التزمت بمخرجات
مؤتمر المناخ كوب سبعه وعشرون والذي عقد
مؤخرا في شرم الشيخ ومن بينها خفض
الانبعاثات من غاز الميثان وتحقيق الحياد
الصفري فضلا عن وضع خطط للاصحاح البيئي
لشركات البترول العامله في خليج السويس
وعملي محطاتي معالجه للصرف الصناعي
ومشروعات تعد الاولى من نوعها بتكلفه 400
دولار يعني انا النهارده بدل مقرمي الميه
بتاعه الصرف الصناعي اللي مش متعلقه على
البحر انا ضريت البحر واهضرت الميه طب انا
افردي عالجتها وعرفت ادخلها ثاني في
العمليات الانتاجيه يبقى بالتالي انا وفرت
لنفسي اقتصاديه ففكره ربطه البيئه
بالاقتصاد يمكن هو ده التوجه اللي احنا
بداناه من ثلاث اربع سنين اه هيبقى التحدي
امام الحفاظ على البيئه مع استمرار
التنميه وحل مشاكل ترى كانت منذ اكثر من
اربعه عقود بدات مصر تخته في حلها بجديه
منذ نحو اربعه اعوام باستخدام تكنولوجيا
حديثه وخطط عمل قصيره وطويله الاجل لمنع
التلوث والتصدي لاي انعكاسات سلبيا من اي
حادث راند ابو العزم العربيه رشوقير خليج
السويس